[Musica]
in questo foglio qui c'è il mio discorso
che avrei dovuto fare inglese così come
gli hanno chiesto però voglio rompere
gli schemi perché il titolo del mio
spitzer il peggio di me come posso darvi
il peggio di me fingendo di saper
parlare una lingua che in realtà non
conosco fin in fondo ci sono delle volte
in cui certe regole vanno distrutte
è un po come è successo con la mia
candidatura a sindaco di palermo quello
che ha visto è un documentario che
racconta da dentro
cosa significa fare il candidato sindaco
in una città difficilissima come palermo
pensate oggi il presidente della cina in
visita a palermo è uno dei più grandi
partiti italiani ha deciso di investire
sul ragazzo come me senza chiedersi se
quel ragazzo era in grado di potere fare
il sindaco della sua città e ciò che
succede adesso nella politica italiana
si cercano soltanto perché sei
comunicativo ai social lei tanti
follower su instagram fai le iene ma non
si pongono il problema di chiedere
d'istituto è in grado di fare quello per
cui ti hanno chiamato io sono cresciuto
a palermo allo zen uno dei quartieri più
difficili
mia madre quando ero piccolo per
sopravvivere ha deciso di riscattare una
casa popolare abusiva è stato per la
prima volta che mi sono reso conto cosa
significava la mafia propri tentacoli
garantisce il welfare del paese
mi sono reso conto subito che aveva una
strada davanti ormai designata mio
cugino arrestato per mafia altro cugino
arrestato per droga
mio zio anche lui arrestato ecco una
scelta da fare stare da questa parte a
stare dall'altra parte della barricata
ho deciso di guardare dentro la mafia da
una posizione privilegiata iniziato a
studiare il fenomeno della criminalità
organizzata
non è stato facile mia madre quando sono
tornato per casa la prima volta mi ha
detto perchè fai questo
perché mettere per il taglio la tua vita
la vita della tua famiglia ho trovata
riversa sul tavolo della cucina che
stava piangendo e lo guardate dicendo
mamma sai
purtroppo in questo paese il giornalismo
è rappresentato da barbara d'urso e
quindi bisogna fare qualcosa
so che dopo queste parole ovviamente mi
licenzieranno da mediaset
voglio salutare
le iene ma il problema di questo paese e
che il giornalismo non racconta più
verità scomode noi ragazzi abbiamo
smesso la capacità di sognare
quanti di voi credono che un'idea ap sei
da una è quella di fare quello che
magari non si doveva fare e visionando
il peggio di me
oggi non voglio farmi capire che questo
ragazzo che mi sta parlando a chi sacco
di grandi qualità quello che ho fatto
semplicemente fare il mio dovere
denunciare un boss della mafia e
mettendo repentaglio la mia vita e
quella della mia famiglia
purtroppo quando vado a palermo i
carabinieri che mi seguono e difficile
farlo spiegare spiegarlo a quel fratello
che voglio tanto bene adesso ma che
quando era piccolo odiava le forze
dell'ordine pensate un po il paradosso
oggi si trova tutelato lui dalle forze
dell'ordine mentre nella sua vita ha
fatto tanti errori no nun po strana la
vita
chi l'avrebbe mai detto che dal profondo
sud oggi avrei potuto essere un uomo di
punta di un partito italiano
ho deciso di essere piuttosto libero di
raccontare verità scomode di tornare a
indossare quella divisa da iena quando
magari sarebbe stato più semplice o
facile stare al governo di questo paese
ma io credo che abbiamo bisogno di
storie di persone vere che non diano
un'immagine di se stesse diversa da
quella che sono
e bello ragazzi dare il peggio di voi
smettiamola di stare dentro quelle
regole quegli schemi di ragazzi perfetti
precisi che devono sempre stare al posto
giusto al momento giusto ho iniziato a
sognare quando ho messo da parte tutti i
limiti che avevo pensato un ragazzo dal
profondo sud di un quartiere difficile
che nasce in una famiglia poverissima
che cosa avrebbe potuto aspirare da
grande delinquere spacciare fare quello
che era normale che tutti quanti
facessero nel mio paese ma una storia
che mi ha insegnato che è possibile
spaccare la storia a metà
guardando un uomo che è venuto da una
città che era sfigato nazareth paesino
piccolo oppure quell'uomo
nonostante la sua realtà ha cambiato la
storia dell'umanità non è minimizzate la
vostra debolezza perché quando sarete
deboli sarete forti quando saprete dare
il peggio di voi sarete in grado di
il meglio di voi io in questo film che
ho raccontato forse per la prima volta
la verità avete visto la versione in
inglese perché non l'avrei non l'abbiamo
ancora pubblicata
ho raccontato semplicemente esperienza
da candidato sindaco in una città
difficile bene forse sto facendo una
cosa che non mi permetterà di entrare a
far parte di quelle che sono gli
standard del telex mondiale è
probabilmente il mio spicci rimarrà qui
preferisco avere parlato con il cuore a
quelli che mi stanno sentendo perché
sono convinto che a volte certe regole
si possono infrangere e magari mi
perdonerete grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]